so und wir schalten wir live zum
g7-treffen in quebec zu ulrich von
heesen ulrich wie viel sinn macht dieser
gipfel eigentlich noch und was mich
eigentlich viel mehr interessiert wo es
ihre hose erster gipfel überhaupt keinen
sinn mehr
und zweitens für so was ziehe ich mir
doch keine hose mehr an der so genannte
westen ist offiziell tot die hasen sich
nur frau merkel ist so sauer die rentier
mit diesem t-shirt
ich war bei 310 g 7 gipfel und alles was
ich gekriegt habe sind beschissen
strafzölle
[Applaus]
die firma sein da war ja die stimmung
bei meinen letzten drei scheidungen
besser 600 millionen kostet der quatsch
ihr für ein gruppenfoto wo sich der
orange netz fabian wieder nach vorne
drängeln
warte mal ich höre gerade der g7 gipfel
heißt jetzt nur noch b 6 die italiener
sind gerade abgereist sie sind
stinksauer wegen der russlands antun und
und weil der rotwein hier scheiße ist
a&p 5 frankreich ist raus marco muss
nach hause
seine frau sagt er schreibt morgen
dateien ulrich ich verstehe diese
veranstaltung sowieso nicht russland
bleibt draußen obwohl ohne die nichts
geht und china dass 20 prozent der
weltwirtschaftsleistung er bringt auch
nicht weil das chinesen sind das
repräsentiert auch nicht die welt ja und
nun das normal ist der letzte gipfel für
die abschlusserklärung konnten sie sich
nur noch auf einen satz einigen was mal
auf wir rufen und liquider an alle
getränke gehen auf donald trumps zimmer
haben sie gesehen wie der die merkel
begrüßt hat das sauerkraut gesicht hast
du zähler auf meine eröffnungsrunde
geparkt ja habe ich und zwar absichtlich
hast ein problem damit dann geh doch
einfach weiter
ja da geht's lang damaliger auch hier
stinkt blöde ziehen
ich habe nur noch kindergarten
das ist doch wirklich kindergarten sagen
sie mal steht da unten jetzt g1 gibt ja
alle weg bis auf merkel g1 ist eh besser
trifft sich einmal im jahr mit sich
selbst auf rügen
so und jetzt muss ich auch mein zimmer
ich mache gleich noch eine
feuerzangenbowle mit den kollegen hatte
ich den brenner eigentlich schon an
gemacht weiß ich jetzt gar nicht naja
von heesen autor ich von heesen
[Applaus]